MARIA: WELCOME BACK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SIGNING THE
LARGEST ECONOMIC STIMULUS
BILL, A RELIEF BILL IN U.S.
HISTORY, AS STATES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY RAMP UP EFFORTS TO
BATTLE THE FAST SPREAD OF
CORONAVIRUS.
SCIENTISTS ARE SCRAMBLING TO
DEVELOP THE VACCINE AND
THERAPEUTICS AS WE SPEAK.
JOINING ME RIGHT NOW IS SOUTH
CAROLINA REPUBLICAN SENATOR
LINDSEY GRAHAM CHAIRMAN OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE,
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE
AND YOU AS WELL HAVE BEEN
WRANGELLING WITH THE IDEA OF
WHETHER OR  NOT TO OPEN THE
ECONOMY DURING THIS PANDEMIC
BUT YOU SAY YOU’VE SPOKEN WITH
DR. FAUCI THIS WEEKEND AND YOU
WANT TO ERR ON THE SIDE OF
CAUTION?
>> YES, SO, I TOLD DR. FAUCI
AND WE’RE AT WAR WITH THE VIRUS,
THERE’S A SPRING CAMPAIGN PLAN
AND A SUMMER CAMPAIGN PLAN AND A
FALL CAMPAIGN PLAN.
THIS WILL COME BACK IN THE FALL
BUT I THINK THE HEAT IN THE
SUMMER WILL LOWER
TRANSMISSIONS.
THE VIRUS GENERALLY DOESN’T DO
WELL IN HEAT, SO HERE IS WHAT
DR. FAUCI SAID.
TO REOPEN THE ECONOMY, YOU HAVE
TO HAVE A BREAKTHROUGH IN
TESTING.
WE’VE GOT TO GET TESTING BACK IN
REALTIME, NOT FOUR OR  FIVE DAYS
, SO IF YOU’VE GOT A COUNTY
OUT THERE WITH NO INFECTIONS THE
ONLY WAY WE CAN SAFELY OPEN
THAT COUNTY UP FOR BUSINESS IS
TO HAVE A TESTING REGIME WE
DON’T HAVE TODAY, SO I’D WAIT
UNTIL IT GOT WARMER BEFORE I
TRIED TO OPEN UP ANY PARTS OF
THE ECONOMY.
WE NEED A RISK ASSESSMENT NEXT
WEEK AND BEFORE WE ACTUALLY
START TURNING THE ECONOMY ON, I
THINK WE NEED A BREAKTHROUGH IN
TESTING AND WE NEED THE SUPPORT
FROM THE SUMMER THAT TO ME BE
THE CAUTIOUS APPROACH.
MARIA: BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT SAYING LOOK THE
CURE CANNOT BE WORSE THAN
THE VIRUS.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A RECESSION
AT HAND, WE’RE ALREADY IN A
CONTRACTION, AND WE’RE EXPECTING
THE ECONOMY TO WORSEN.
NO BUSINESS.
NO PROFITS, NO ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
WHATSOEVER.
>> YEAH, THAT’S THE BALANCE
WE’RE TRYING TO MAKE, TO TRY TO
CREATE A BUMP IN THE ECONOMY YOU
DON’T WANT TO CREATE A SPIKE IN
DISEASE.
THE PRESIDENT SAID SAFETY FIRST,
ECONOMIC REBOUNDING SECOND, AND
THIS PACKAGE IS GOING TO BE A
LIFELINE TO PEOPLE OUT OF WORK
AND A LIFELINE TO BUSINESSES WHO
HAVE NO REVENUE, SO THIS BILL WE
PASS IS GOING TO HELP PEOPLE FOR
A COUPLE OF MONTHS.
THE SUMMER WILL BE HERE BEFORE
YOU KNOW IT AND IN THE SPRING
WHAT I WOULD DO IS RAMP UP MY
MEDICAL SUPPLIES, I’D TRY TO
FOCUS ON TESTING, ANTIBIOTICS
AND THERAPIES TO DESTROY THE
DISEASE IN THE FALL SO THIS
RISK ASSESSMENT THAT’S
COMING OUT NEXT WEEK ABOUT WHAT
PARTS OF THE ECONOMY YOU MAY
REOPEN, I DON’T THINK YOU CAN
SAFELY OPEN UP ANY PART OF THE
ECONOMY UNTIL WE HAVE MORE
TESTING.
MARIA: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THIS
STIMULUS BILL THAT’S RELIEF
PACK PACKAGE, IF YOU WILL, THAN
ANYTHING ELSE.
YOU HAD ISSUE WITH THE LOOPHOLE
AROUND UNEMPLOYMENT, BASICALLY
GIVING MONEY TO PEOPLE TO STAY
AT HOME.
EXPLAIN THAT FORU SENATOR.
OKAY SO IF YOU MAKE $15 AN HOUR
FOR A 40 HOUR WEEK THAT’S $600 A
WEEK.
MY GOAL WAS TO MAKE SURE THAT IN
THE UNEMPLOYMENT PART OF THE
PACKAGE, WE MADE YOU WHOLE,
THAT YOU WERE LAID OFF, NO FAULT
TO YOUR OWN, YOU’D GET $600 A
WEEK.
WHAT WE DID IN THE PACKAGE IS WE
PLUCKED UP UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
SO YOU’LL GET $926 A WEEK IF YOU
LIVE IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
WE INCREASED YOUR PAY BY 50%.
THAT’S GOING TO MAKE IT HARDER
TO GET PEOPLE BACK INTO THE
WORKFORCE, INCENTIVIZE
PEOPLE NOT TO GO BACK INTO THE
WORKFORCE, AND IT’S GOING TO
MAKE IT HARDER FOR PEOPLE TO
HIRE NEW EMPLOYEES.
IF YOU’RE AMAZON AND WALMART,
THE HOURLY WAGE TO, WOULD IN
SOUTH CAROLINA TO NOT WORK IS $
23.14.
I’M ALL FOR HELPING PEOPLE, BUT
THEY TELL US THAT THE STATE
LEVEL IT WOULD TAKE SIX TO EIGHT
MONTHS TO CREATE A COMPUTER
PROGRAM TO PAY THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE STATE UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFIT AND YOUR ACTUAL AGE, SO
WHAT DO WE DO?
WE JUST PUT $600 ON TOP OF IT SO
WE TOOK
WE TOOK A $15 AN HOUR EMPLOYEE
WHO WAS MAKING $600 WORKING,
WE’RE GOING TO PAY THEM $926 IN
SOUTH CAROLINA NOT TO WORK.
WE NEED TO FIX THAT.
MARIA: HOW ARE YOU GOING TO FIX
IT?
>> GET SOME STATE TO FIGURE
SOFTWARE THAT CAN PAY THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
MAXIMUM BENEFIT PER WEEK OF
326 AND $600.
THEY TELL ME THAT CAN’T BE DONE.
WE SENT TWO MEN TO THE MOON.
NOW STEVEN MNUCHIN THIS IS NOT
HIS FAULT.
WE HAVE A $600 FEDERAL BENEFIT
ON TOP OF THE STATE BENEFIT.
WE HAVE A SITUATION WHERE PEOPLE
GETTING 100% PAY RAISE NOT TO
WORK.
WE’VE GOT TO FIX THAT, SOME
SMART PERSON NEEDS TO DEVELOP
SOFTWARE THAT CAN PAY YOUR
ACTUAL WAGES, NOT INCREASE YOUR
WAGES AND UNEMPLOYMENT.
MARIA: WELL TAKE US BEHIND THE
CURTAIN TO TELL US HOW THIS
ALL SHOOK OUT, SENATOR,
BECAUSE NANCY PELOSI SAID SHE
DID JU JITSU ON THIS RELIEF BILL
TO GET IT WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE
AND THIS MORNING THIS WEEKEND
SHE IS SAYING THE PRESIDENT IS
FIDDLING AROUND WHILE PEOPLE ARE
DYING, SENATOR.
>> [LAUGHTER]
NO, WHAT SHE SAID SHE’S BLAMING
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES FOR PEOPLE DYING BECAUSE
OF THE WAY HE’S LED THE COUNTRY.
THAT’S THE MOST SHAMEFUL
DISGUSTING STATEMENT BY ANY
POLITICIAN IN MODERN HISTORY.
LET ME TELL YOU WE’VE SEEN THE
BEST OF AMERICA FROM OUR
CITIZENS, HELPING EACH OTHER,
DELIVERING GROCERIES, HAVING
SPECIAL SHOPPING HOURS FOR
SENIOR CITIZENS.
SHE’S THE FIRST POLITICIAN TO
BLAME ANOTHER POLITICIAN FOR
PEOPLE DYING.
THIS IS THE SAME SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE WHO HELD UP THE BILL IN
THE SENATE FOR DAYS BECAUSE SHE
WANTED SAME DAY VOTING.
SHE WANTED CARBON NEUTRALITY FOR
THE AIRLINES.
SHE WANTED $75 MILLION FOR THE
ENDOWMENT FOR THE
HUMANITIES AND
$25 MILLION FOR THE KENNEDY
CENTER.
SHE IS THE ONE THAT HELD UP THE
PACKAGE IN THE SENATE FOR
DAYS TO GET THE GREEN NEW
DEAL PUT IN A RECOVERY PACKAGE
SO IT’S THE MOST SHAPE FULL
DISGUSTING THING I’VE HEARD YET
AND IT NEEDS TO STOP.
MARIA: WELL, YOU AGREED TO SEND
$25 MILLION TO THE KENNEDY
CENTER YOU PUT THAT IN A
SO-CALLED RELIEF BILL, RIGHT?
>> YEAH, SO SHE PUT A GUN TO
OUR HEAD AND SAID WE WILL NOT
GET THIS THROUGH THE HOUSE UNTIL
YOU PUT $25 MILLION TO THE
KENNEDY CENTER.
SHE WANTED THE ENTIRE NEW GREEN
DEAL IN THE PACKAGE.
SHE WANTED TO HAVE EVERY AIRLINE
HAS TO BE CARBON NEUTRAL BY 2025
WHAT THE HELL HAS THAT GOT TO DO
WITH SAVING LIVES EFFECTED BY
THE CORONAVIRUS?
SHE HAD THE ENTIRE GREEN NEW
DEAL IN THE PACKAGE.
WE TOOK MOST OF THE GARBAGE OUT,
BUT FOR HER TO BLAME THIS
PRESIDENT FOR CAUSING LOSS
OF LIFE AFTER SHE HELD UP THE
RELIEF PACKAGE FOR DAYS TO
GET A LIBERAL SPECIAL INTEREST
SHOPPING LIST IN THE BILL IS
PRETTY DISGUSTING.
MARIA: THAT’S EXTRAORDINARY.